hi I'm Annie Onishi Annie Onishi is a
surgery resident no no I graduated
residency I'm a fellow in trauma surgery
and critical care now
you asked for it I'm back breaking down
more clips from film and TV roadside
liver surgery
the good doctor here's your liver I'm
gonna need you to sign for it how long
ago did you take it out three hours
we just lost three hours technically
three hours and five minutes your clocks
on the cooler so once an organ has been
removed from a donor that starts the
clock for what's called the cold
ischemic time that is the amount of time
that the organ is not actively receiving
blood flow from the original patient and
from the recipient what about a police
escort my doctor's an MD does actually
personally deliver that cooler you get
to write on an airplane sometimes get to
write in the back of an ambulance lights
and sirens it can be pretty exciting I
don't know what you're looking for sure
yes I can feel it it's firmer I don't
know what that means there must be a
clot but there isn't a clot this can
show no clot there's no way you would be
able to detect a clot or a thrombus
inside the liver that's just not unless
you had an ultrasound vision of the tips
of your fingers you wouldn't be able to
do that we have to immediately remove
the clot and flush the left lobe to
protect it from the ice baths you don't
need to protect the liver from the ice
bath I'm not sure what he's talking
about okay we need to stop the car
sure yes yes we need to operate right
[Applause]
so great thank googled queen of segments
that's like super cutting-edge super
accurate so the Queen ode segments are
how we anatomically divide the liver
based on its blood supply and its
biliary drainage so there are segments
one through eight this is correctly
labeled it's missing segment 4a and 4b
but other than that that's that's pretty
good this is also not what a liver looks
like so when a Limor is procured from a
donor it actually comes with a bunch of
stuff attached to it so it comes with
the the big portal triad attached to it
that has a basically the business end of
the liver how the liver drains it comes
a little piece of intestine attached to
it still bunch of blood vessels in the
back we bring more than we're going to
need basically it does not look like
that this is better than having a baby
in my car do not put that liver into me
subcutaneous infestation evolution I
would put a tourniquet on the leg and
trap it and then and go after it that's
what I would do
going the other way how you going in
rectally personally I don't think I
could get to this directly it does look
pretty simcha taneous agree there is
always time for lubricant Oh clinch so
as an expert in rectal foreign body
surgery telling the patient not to
clench is not gonna work you really have
to give these people a lot of sedation
and get them pretty much totally asleep
if you're gonna go up there and fish
something out he looks like he's in a
ton of pain and obviously very
uncomfortable there's no chance of
getting anything out
I've never personally seen a bug like
that craw from the leg into the colon
what do we do the only bugs I've ever
encountered have been in Kenya there's
an intestinal parasite called ascariasis
it's a series of tapeworms that end up
living inside the intestinal tract and
actually cause obstructions don't you
ever do that again
Craig Oh thyroid out of me from anaconda
[Music]
that's not exactly how you do that a
cricothyrotomy is an emergency procedure
that is performed when a patient has
their airway that cannot be intubated
from their mouth so looks to me like the
indication here for Craig is that this
patient has some sort of wasp in his
upper airway so maybe there's some
swelling in the airway so typically a
breathing tube will go into the mouth
into the trachea and then we can connect
that tube to a breathing machine so the
patient can still breathe in an
emergency situation like this yeah I
would probably just use my knife get
down to the cricothyroid membrane and
yes enter sharply like he did there I'm
not sure what kind of tube it is but it
looks like a reasonably sized tube but
they would need to start ventilating
right away it doesn't work if you just
stick it in there you have to breathe
for the person chaotic emergency Grey's
Anatomy
I can't frighten the doctor here says
that she can't crike and I don't know
why I can almost always cry he's got
stuck you emphysema and this thing that
she says sub-q emphysema what that
refers to is that child has air in the
skin and and soft tissues on the chest
that's usually a sign that something
really bad has happened to this kid he
probably does an emergency chest tube
and he certainly needs his airway
controlled somehow all right
- orange drawer orange drawer
I knew that no chest sounds on the right
HSP seconds anybody actually have chest
tubes so clearly in this chaos the
nurses are not here so the doctors are
trying to do the job of both the doctors
and the nurses and this is what would
happen I'm trying to set up this saline
drip and I can't get just like to stop
beeping anyone so that's a hundred
percent accurate so when doctors like me
try to set up IV pumps which is normally
the nurses job usually we can't figure
it out usually there's bubbles there's
beeping there's alarms nothing works and
a nurse usually has to come and rescue
me IV drip rate it's different for kids
depending on the size so anybody the
calculator how's that taste Izzy's 30
kilos that broselow tape that's a real
thing so when a child comes in it is a
tape that you literally measure their
body length with and it will give you
the best estimate for how much that kid
weighs as far as our taste is he's 30
kilos and a concentration of dopamine is
1,600 mics per CC so 5 times 30 is 150
times 60 minutes and hours 9,000 divide
that by 1,600 infusion rate is 5 point
65 cc's per hour so that's the kind of
math that nurses do in their heads all
the time or they have memorized from
giving this medication so frequently I
feel like an idiot brain transplant and
get out
so in get out they perform a series of
really barbaric and racially driven
brain transplants luckily in my opinion
brain transplant is not a thing and
probably won't ever be a thing
rookie mistake you're all sterile you're
all scrubbed in and then you touch your
mask start over
so technically those glasses don't count
as eye protection he's a psychopath that
he should really know more about sterile
technique in real brain surgery you
don't actually remove the skullcap you
made sort of a curvilinear incision
along the plane of what part of the
school you're gonna remove so this is
clearly dr. Armitage is special torturer
brain surgery tre oh wait I am so
confused
I don't really recognize any of those
instruments
I think the instruments second from the
bottom looks a little bit like something
called a Roger which is how you remove
bone fragments from things I see some
suture scissors
up next honestly the thing on the left
looks like a speculum for lady parts but
I'm not sure man I've told you not to go
in that house directing your own surgery
Ronin I've done this many times before
we just cut up there just a little but
the operating surgeon here is using an
11 blade that's typically not really
used on skin in this manner typically to
make the first incision on the skin and
use a 15 later a 10 blade take the clip
this is a sponge stick
you see a ton of sponge sticks in
medical dramas it's unbelievable
this is not how you use a sponge stick
a sponge stick is typically used deep in
the body it's a piece of gauze wrapped
around what's called a ring forceps
I'm sure it's used to very gently
retract a very delicate structures that
are deep and in the way it's not used to
the lot that's open it up spreads but
Robert DeNiro is describing spread
spread spread which means actually
inserting the tips of that instrument
and spreading tissue so you can make a
cavity bigger that is a maneuver that we
in surgery very commonly if we need to
get access to a certain place dropping
someone off at the year and then leaving
Hustler's this is actually a thing we
sort of tongue-in-cheek refer to this as
the homey drop usually it's because
either they happen to be right by the
hospital when they got hurt or
somebody's too scared to call the cops
or call EMS usually we're just grateful
that they brought the patient to medical
attention so we can help them heart
surgery from Krank - mm-hmm
that is not what the human heart looks
like first of all it doesn't continue
beating once it's all disconnected
without sounding too creepy yes we do
comment on people's insides so as silly
as that looks that does actually exist
in real life it's called a total
artificial heart it's usually used as a
bridge to a transplant for a patient who
has something very very wrong with their
with the actual muscle of their heart
yes this is definitely some back-alley
heart surgery I really would not
recommend going to these doctors Jack's
appendectomy lost
[Music]
so you do actually flick the needle like
that that's to get the little air
bubbles out so you don't inject air into
the patient no Jack they found some
chloroform at the medical station I
could not you out managed with the
lidocaine lidocaine is a local
anesthetic that's used to numb the area
it's what you commonly might get in your
gums at the dentist that is a massive
incision for an Appy that was huge
totally unnecessary
a penis short for appendectomy which is
the surgical operation to remove the
appendix spreader I think that she's
probably asking for what's called a
self-retaining retractor that's a little
skimmer tracker that would stay open by
itself freeing your hands okay look
that's actually what's called a finished
shuttle retractor
not typically used on the abdomen I'm
sorry jack right well he's just being
loud and fidgety I would want him
knocked out too but we actually there's
a lot of reasons we put patients under
general anesthesia for surgery obviously
one is comfort the other is total muscle
relaxation so we actually give you a
little bit of a paralytic so your
muscles completely relax and that
actually makes incisions on the
abdominal wall much easier would you
rather be dreaming about something nice
back home eating human brain from
Hannibal see the brain itself feels no
pain carries that that concerns you so
it is actually true the brain itself has
no pain fibers so once the patient has
been sedated and the craniectomy part
has been performed they don't actually
didn't have the brain in any way here's
the sack that contains the brain
so here this little membrane dr.
Lecter's removing is something called
the dura it's not really that stretchy
or kind of shiny like that or rippable
like that but that is an actual layer
that protects the brain between the
brain tissue itself and the skull and if
you look at this diagram here you can
see all the different layers in the head
so you have the scalp the skull and
there's a potential space with the
different layers of dura followed
finally by the brain tissue actually
below all of that that's smells great I
personally prefer mine with a little
more garlic than that but I'm sure this
is fine though I'm not a brain surgeon I
do know that in some neurosurgical
procedures the patient is actually wide
awake so that fine elegant tasks such as
speech or fine motor movement can
continue to be tested while the surgeon
is operating on that particular area of
the brain so that way the surgeon knows
this is the area that's controlling this
for this patient we shouldn't cut that
we shouldn't touch that self surgery in
Wolverine
I gotta get that thing first of all I
wish my scalpel is attached to my hand
like that that'd be pretty cool that
looks like pretty pure CGI to me doesn't
look like real x-ray there are some
operations that we do use active x-ray
so we can monitor certain parts of the
body while we operate on them keep going
so our orthopedic colleagues always use
something called the CRM which is a
dynamic moveable x-ray to take pictures
of the bones as they're getting fixed
same thing with vascular surgeons they
very commonly use x-ray to take pictures
of the blood vessels that they're
operating on and to fix those blood
vessels so the use of x-ray in and of
itself during surgery is very common the
surgical checklist er don't remember
being asked if dr. Benton could scrub in
for this this is an example of how a
surgeon comes in with his hands sterile
and somebody else helps them get dressed
put him under let's do this little whoa
what about the checklist excuse me
safe surgery checklist this safe surgery
checklist is a real thing that's
practiced every day in every operating
room in this country I've had 10 cases
today doctor
it only took a minute 1 minute John
Carter here for a right cadaveric renal
allograft does the patient have a known
allergy no does anesthesia anticipate a
difficulty array no is the risk of
bleeding greater than 500 CCS so that's
a great representation of a surgical
time out that's really thorough it goes
through all the major important things
any nursing concerns you don't have any
reperfusion solution we won't be needing
it they said they didn't have enough
profusing the solution in the room so
the nurse went to go get it and that's
gonna save them some trouble later on in
the operation so people aren't rushing
around trying to get what's needed I
think that this is an excellent teaching
opportunity we take this practice from
airline safety so before an airplane
takes off the pilot the copilot and the
air traffic controller go through a
checklist where they check every single
system on the airplane make sure
everything's in working order before the
plane takes off a surgical checklist is
the same thing we make sure that we have
identified the proper patient that we're
doing the correct operation that we have
all the equipment we could
we need and it really is meant to reduce
medical errors and surgical errors now
let's just take that time and introduce
the wrong she'll Elaine scrub nurse
paula cheney circulating nurse a
Schumacher anesthesiologist her hand a
loperamide shift surgical resident
Ethan Dean Surgical intern that's
actually a great representation of who
all is in an operating room he had the
attending he had two assistants that
resin in the intern those two nurses
they're the circulator and the scrub
tech as well as the anesthesiologist
this is actually very accurate warning
antibiotics given in the last sixty
minutes just starting them now
if you running any biotics prior to
incision you cut the risk of infection
by half dr. Benton
you're a guest here and I don't like
guests as a friend of the patient you're
welcome to sit observe and shut up in
real life surgeons are definitely not
that impatient they will absolutely wait
for the antibiotic to go in because they
don't want the patient to get an
infection any concerns from the surgical
team only that you're wasting my time so
it seems like this surgeon who's about
to do this operation is sort of anti
checklist that's really a no-go these
days so we always do a time out in a
matter way that has a lawsuit waiting to
happen impersonating a nurse the dark
night
so nurses do where Nursing Uniforms
that's a little outdated old school most
of them are just regular scrub tops and
a uniform top that just says RN in the
name of the hospital so if Harvey Dent
really had a burn like that in real life
he would be intubated he don't be on a
bunch of medications receiving a ton of
IV fluids he would be really really sick
and really not able to fight back when
the Joker comes and here in the
background you see some coronal images
which is a means a picture taken in this
dimension of the body that looks like an
MRI slice of a brain it looks pretty
normal I'm not sure why Harvey Dent
would have needed to have had an MRI I
don't want there to be any hard feelings
between us Harvey a patient intakes are
a Parks and Rec everything you write
down is confidential we need you to give
real answers so there are definitely
some patients I meet that are not super
trusting of doctors it's okay you know
it usually comes from probably a bad
experience but there are better ways
than what she's doing to sort of work
around that and get the patient alarm up
to you a little bit Ronde you redacted
all the information answered some of
them for date of birth you wrote
springtime you should be a little more
friendly her tone is little terse she
looks a little impatient her facial
features are not super friendly warm
welcoming or patient so she could
probably take a chill pill and try again
organ procurement Robocop to make it
fast because six minutes before the
I'm not sure what she's talking about
the brain is always gonna be this list
there's no such thing as a brain
transplant so this is the way how they
would brain surgeons like to do crazy
activies which is like a full top
skullcap craniectomy but that's not
really how it's done in real life as far
as I know there's no suction cup effect
but correct me if I'm wrong so this
makes no sense at all
so this guy supposed to be dead this is
a bypass machine so the bypass machine
is pumping blood for him in a supposedly
dead body so not terribly consistent I
have never seen a dissection like that I
don't think you can get all those parts
out together unblocked like that I mean
to transplant organs you just put them
in a little bag with ice in a plastic
bucket you don't use this bubbling the
fishtank sort of set up I've never seen
that before
we're all literally a gunshot wound from
Seraphim Falls you don't necessarily
need to remove a bullet just because you
have a bullet inside but if you want to
have Pierce browse and take his shirt
off and flex this is a good excuse to do
it so you could definitely use a red-hot
metal blade to cauterize a wound but
that thing was not actively bleeding so
I really I would just have left that
alone another shirtless guy using fire
to cauterize his wound
Rambo three
[Music]
here's another guy with limited medical
resources and what appears to be a soft
tissue injury in the absence of you know
hemorrhage or something that really
needs to be controlled I would just I
would just leave these wounds alone but
I think this is pretty reasonable
technique to cauterize but again
completely unnecessary serious I'm
serious the janitor makes the diagnosis
the fugitive can you give us a hand here
you bring this kid down to observation
room - it would not be typical for
someone from the housekeeping staff to
transport a patient
this doctor / janitor is looking at the
x-ray what looks like a baby you can
tell sort of from the dimensions of the
chest and the way the bones look he's
also looking at that x-ray backwards you
can tell because the heart is not where
it's supposed to be
[Music]
your brother
they downstairs I can't exactly tell
he's crossing out and what he's about to
write but on any medical record it would
be really suspicious to cross something
out you'd have to get new for him
investors so patient handoff doesn't
really work like that these days
usually it's a series of phone calls
from the nurse in the ER to the
accepting nurse and the o.r on the floor
same thing with the doctors there's a
series of what we call handoffs about
the patient what the diagnosis is what
workups has been done what other tests
don't need to get done it's usually not
like this where it's kind of a
word-of-mouth and a trust this guy in
the janitorial uniform to give me this
Candace diagnosis that's a little
suspect I don't typically affectionately
rub the faces of my patients before they
get wheeled off the surgery no that's
not really my style horse tranquilizers
are straight to the neck old-school
what kind of good is this that's a
tranquilizer gun not exactly sure what
tranquilizer was in that tranquilizer
dart but one common tranquilizer that we
might use in the emergency setting is
something called ketamine yes it is a
drug that works very quickly it doesn't
cause any major hemodynamic shifts
meaning it will alter your blood
pressure too much and it's a quick on
quick off kind of drugs so it's pretty
it's a pretty good medication to sedate
a person in the emergency room if you
have to do some some quick procedures we
so definitely as the medication is
setting in patients will start to feel
foggy start to feel groggy and may yeah
I have some mental slowing whoa
impersonating a doctor catch me if you
can gentlemen what uh what seems to be
the problem
bicycle accident spongy check strikes
again actual tibia about five inches
patella dr. Harris yes do you concur I
mean he sort of looks like a doctor he
talks like a doctor I think he could
probably trick a couple people but I
think that this is a little bit of a
stretch I think we should take an x-ray
then stick him out you put him in a
walking cast so I completely disagree
with his suggestion I get this kid in a
walking cast what that looks like is
called what we call an open fracture
meaning you can see the bone through the
injury so that actually is pretty
involved it's usually more of a severe
injury that patient you should probably
go up to the operating room get a really
good washout for concern for infection
and probably get some surgery to fix
that bone a dead giveaway here is the
nausea most doctors aren't too squeamish
here's an example of a patient arrival
in code black 16 year old boy fell down
stairs minor
okay hey how you doing buddy fine I fell
this is all probably overkill
did you see Danson sir no I did anything
else you can tell us nothing so this is
a pretty good example of the first
responders doing what's called giving
report they are bringing the patient in
they're telling the doctors and nurses
in the hospital what happened to the
patient this sounds like this patient
fell on a set of stairs minor burns no
ko when they say no ko means no loss of
consciousness or no knockout anything
else you can tell us so here we have two
nurses sort of dividing and conquering
one nurse is getting what's called
collateral history from the person who
came into the hospital with the kid and
the other nurse is attending to the
child's medical needs right now except
really dumb actually I fell down some
stairs this seems like a pretty stable
patient with a relatively minor
mechanism of injury so for that reason
there's no trauma team or a bunch of
surgeons running around trying to figure
out what happened at the kid it's pretty
much just nurses at this point
tick-borne illness house has tick
paralysis
dan tracked a tick onto his jeans quite
still ordinarily cosinus electric shock
this girl's allergies are not ordinary
administering SP it's just gonna get
worse
so that bag-valve-mask that's like
atrocious right there bag valve mask
ventilation is seen here with this
purple that's called an Ambu bag as well
as that mask that's on the patient's
face that Ambu bag should be squeezed in
a very particular way to observe the
Chester eyes on a certain rate so the
rate at which she is squeezing which is
really fast that's gonna cause a couple
things number one is hyperventilation
number two she's just gonna fill that
patient's stomach with air which can
cause a lot of other problems down the
road as long as we're stuck here it's
like a good time to look for that tick
actually was wearing off
so he says here the atropine is wearing
off atropine is a medication that we
would use for bradycardia which is when
the heart rate is really slow so it
sounds like she got really bradycardic
they gave her atropine it's wearing off
meaning her heart is slowing down again
and on the monitor you see that her
heart rate is 45 so it's pretty slow we
treat her symptoms she dies we find the
cause she lives that tick is an IV drip
of poison we unhook it she'll be fine oh
my god see usually with tick borne
illness you get like a what's called a
dilated cardiomyopathy but that takes
like weeks to months tada
this is that's just this is not real I
don't know how to tell you conclusion I
realized that a lot of what Hollywood
does in the or in the ER is for dramatic
effect but it's pretty fun to check out
what they do right and what they do
wrong and don't forget if you're
enjoying technique critique subscribe to
Wired